welcome to this video playing John
Stewart plant Jon Stewart plant this is
the actual name of the guy maybe oh is
this some kind of person I should know
the fella dorm young the freedom that is
this wacky line was g4 let's try that
okay she seems to to know it Wow playing
really quickly
oh come on don't tell me you really
you're an expert on this stuff while I
don't have a slightest idea I mean I'm
500 points I are rated which does not
mean I should be winning automatically
or something but really you know all
this stuff and when h3 is a bit of a
layman's but I I wasn't sure I cannot go
F for my clothes should i play yeah now
let's let's get ahead f4 try to activate
quickly and d5 maybe you can go 25
okay let's see get so the slopes looks
very dangerous for black and just
putting it really really might line who
take p7 now 95 no I have five Quincy six
check okay
okay jack wow this looks really really
dangerous 95 or is there some better
move Queen Queenie for no 2070 cannot
play I'm probably overlooking a simple
when here ah come on think think think
95 i Luke CA them okay Brandon let's do
that it's it's simple it's good just
keeping a great position he needs to
play um 97 now I can just develop and
the tech with no big big things to to to
calculate okay m to f 3 yeah
it's hard to untangle I'm threatening
Bishop takes d5 awesome
Queen a4 was interesting Queen d7 Bishop
b5 yeah the weather that sets too late
now but it's got a hard time anyway how
do you protect c5 oopsie aid yeah then
not sure should I play at five yeah well
I can take the six now yeah and I will
okay look look c6
yeah Queen B seven astrophysics check I
don't want I want to tempo him not
retreating now Bishop shapewear pick up
a six even threatening Bishop b5 of
course i'd like to make sure he cannot
cancel yeah maybe this one the easiest
to prevent castles there should be seven
i can just take and now there's a five
hanging oops
yeah threatening look f6 it doesn't
react to that I can take it Wow
no really I don't tell me you plant that
and this game is really weird what I
have no way to to protect this now or
really
cannot believe it i don't see when I
don't see a win okay unbelievable
no Knight f5 is a big threat
or the check can not not sure that this
is good yeah come on this is Whitney now
isn't it this stuff I run really shocked
me check this strange double attack
okay yeah I am 1 39 seconds but
unfortunately quite easy to play I can
just push the edge born now check Nate
yeah I can couldn't do anything anymore
but at this this was super weird stuff
he blundered that one than here and then
really rooke f6 Rock f 6 24 it's a
[ __ ] unbelievable really unbelievable
I mean white Dwight is still very good
shape of course but still this was
really a shocker Queen g3 is much better
attacking here and still having this
this on this is just two pieces up yeah
this is still winning but how strange is
that yeah I have no idea about the
opening around around here I was
thinking I should should really win out
check check this is probably winning and
TM yeah I saw this too late check this
possibility winning a quite substantial
material and he cannot he cannot afford
that you don't don't survive that
no um okay I missed a simple simple
stuff here just taking and then Quincy
six it's much much easier much easier
alright thanks for watching